[Musique]
nous sommes le mercredi 24 juin bonsoir
merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction de TVfil 78 voici les
principaux titres que nous allons
développer ce soir si semaine au lieu de
5 coups d'envoi des soles d'été ce matin
et des commerçants plutôt confiant
ambiance dans les centres commerciaux et
conseil aussi de la Direction
Départementale de protection des
populations à suivre Pierre Bédier veut
la tête de l'office de l'office HLM au
Pivois et cela fait grincer quelques
dents le représentant des locataires de
ce bailleur le plus important
d'Île-de-France craint un démembrement
dans les prochains mois un démembrement
néfaste pour lui pour les résidents les
élections régionales et le Front
National qui s'engage dans la campagne
valérant de Saint-Juste tête de liste en
Île de France était en déplacement dans
les ivelines les soles de d'été 2015
lancé ce matin jusqu'au 4 août des
promotions pour les clients mais aussi
des obligations pour les commerçants
nous en parlerons tout à l'heure avec
Joël Ayache de la direction
départemental de la protection des
populations invité du journal mais en
attendant comment avez-vous vécu cette
première journée de solde le reportage
de Mélanie poquet et de William
l les boutiques sont ouvertes depuis 1
heure et des clients sont déjà là en
cette première journée ça démarre en
douceur même accompagné du dernier né
fait des soldes pour habiller ben la
famille on n pas le choix voilà on a
ouvert à 8h30 ce matin et plutôt bien
donc on a un bon ressenti par rapport à
une dernière c'est plutôt bien donc on
va voir là c'est ça reste relativement
cas mais les gens achètent cette année
encore c'est le portefeuille qui va
décider selon une étude 50 % des
Français estiment que leur situation
économique s'est détériorée ils viennent
chercher le besoin je pense aussi le
coup de cœur qu'ils ont vu quelques
temps auparavant et effectivement aussi
les bonnes affaires
mais avant tout je pense que ils veulent
aussi se faire plaisir pour ma fille ça
sera dans les dans les 100 € à peu près
c'est plus moins
qu'avant c'est moins c'est moins depuis
quelques temps oui oui ouis parce que la
vie est plus difficile et que voilà a
beaucoup de frais il y a son frère qui
grandit aussi donc il a besoin aussi
donc on restera un petit peu le budget
près de 6 Français sur 10 prévoi de
consacrer pour leurs achats un panier
moyen d'environ 145 € et 70 % des
consommateurs prévoient d'attendre les
2è et 3è démarques ici moi c'est on
entame direct du - 30- 40 - 50 alors les
gens ils arrivent dès qu'ils trouvent
quelque chose qui leur plaît ils
n'hésitent pas à prendre
quoi cette année pas de solde flottant
la période est rallongée d'une semaine
les bonnes affaires pourront se dénicher
jusqu'au mardi 4
août Joë aage bonsoir vous êtes le chef
du service des pratiques commerciales à
la direction départementale de la
protection des populations aujourd'hui
début des soldes tout d'abord une
première remarque on l'a entendu dans le
reportage ce ne sont pas 5 semaines de
soldes mais 6 les soldes flottantes qui
disparaissent c'était censé être la
nouveauté il y a quelques temps et
finalement on est revenu dessus tout à
fait c'est donc depuis le 1er janvier
2015 donc il y a la disparition des
seuls flottants et la période
réglementée des sollds passe de 5 à 6
semaines et le travail pour vous a
débuté avant même cette période parce
aujourd'hui une grosse journée mais le
travail débute en fait le travail
concernant les les promotions s'effectue
toute l'année alors avant les soldes
évidemment donc les agents de la des DPP
de mon service sont déjà allés faire des
relevés de prix sur le terrain pour
pouvoir comme les clients pour pouvoir
après vérifier que les Rabet annoncés
sont véritables et ça va se poursuivre
tout au long de la période des soldes il
sont combien ces agents moi j'ai une il
y a une dizaine de d'agents qui sont
dédiés au contrôle notamment des soldes
mais qui contrôlent également d'autres
d'autres aspects des promotions alors
les soldes justement quels sont les
produits les articles qui peuvent être
soldés alors les prod alors les produits
peuvent être soldé en fait mais ça alors
il y a plusieurs d'abord une définition
des soldes donc les soldes doivent être
annoncé comme tendante à une un
écoulement du du stock des marchandises
elle doit elles doivent se dérouler donc
pendant une période donnée pendant une
période définie par décret qui est donc
comme on l'a ditant votre reportage qui
va du du 24 juin au 4 août et elles
peuvent concerner des produits euh qui
sont qui sont détenus euh en fait depuis
moins depuis depuis au moins un mois on
peut pas faire des stocks spécifiques
les commerçants pour voilà en fait
contrairement à ce qu'on appelle les les
promotions h pendant les soldes les
commerçants ne peuvent pas se
réapprovisionner c'est vraiment pour
guider des stocks qui sont là depuis
depuis plusieurs semain donc nos agents
sont sont chargé de vérifier en fait
notamment la détention des marchandises
que c'est que ces marchandises ont bien
été payées par le commerçant au un mois
avant le début de la période des soldes
on va s'attarder sur les les fraudes que
vous constatez peut-être le plus souvent
juste une parenthèse il y a souvent
cette mention la mention pendant les
soldes ni repris ni échangé c'est une
mention abusive alors euh c'est plus
compliqué que ça donc ni ni échanger ni
euh ni repris en fait ça ça ça dépend en
fait euh théoriquement c'est ça ça
relève du du civil donc en fait les
marchandises c'est vrai que les
marchandises légalement ne peuvent pas
le le commerçant a le droit de de dire
ni ni échanger ni repris sauf s'il y a
un vis caché d'un produit ou ce qu'on
appelle un vis rédiibitoire et dans ce
cas-làticle est abîmé par exemple si
l'article est abîmé s'il y a une tâche
et cetera donc donc en fait ce ce ce
cette
disposition s'applique pendant les
soldes ou en dehors des soldes donc on
peut pas on peut pas dire on peut pas
dire que ni repris ni échanger n'est pas
il y a une petite nuance malgré tout
c'est pour la vente sur Internet la
vente sur Internet là les articles sont
repris il y a un de 14 jours qui
s'applique on n pas sous la même voilà
en fait c'est la législation sur
Internet c'est le le code de la
consommation c'est sur la la vente à
distance et donc là il y a prévu un
délai de rétractation qui est de 14
jours et donc là les articles peuvent
être donc échangés euh au bout de 14
jours ils ont 14 jours après la
livraison du produit là vous
n'intervenez pas sur Internet hein pour
vos services mag nos services peuvent
font des contrôles sur Internet hein les
les services en fait de la des DPP et et
plus particulièrement de la direction
générale de la concurrence et de la
consommation font des contrôles sur
internet il contrôle que les annonces
sont sont bien légales sur internet il
contrôlent les mentions et il contrôle
évidemment que les les rabais sont
véridiques donc il y a un contrôle sur
Internet et après il y a un contrôle
physique des des magasins queles sont
les fraudes que vous constatez le plus
sou alors les fraudes les plus
constamment constaté en fait sont
les les FAAB les fauxabé on gonfle un
petit peu le prix de départ on peut
gonfler également le prix de départ donc
et notre service en fait il y a une
réglementation qui concerne les annonces
de de réduction de prix donc il y a il y
a un arrêté et nos nos services en fait
sont chargés de constater s'il y a pas
ce qu'on appelle des pratiques
commerciales trompeuses et en fait si
les constater des pratiques commerciales
trompeuses et donc il y a une procédure
pénale qui est qui est mise en œuvre et
puisque nous avons parfois le sentiment
de se faire un petit peu arnaquer
pendant cette période de solde nous
sommes allés vous poser cette question
vous êtes-vous déjà fait avoir tout
simplement pendant les soldes micro
trottoir sans doute mais sans m'en
rendre compte non non généralement tous
les les prix affichés sont respectés non
pas à ma connaissance je repère les
bonnes affaires et en fonction de mes
besoins parce que j'achète pas pour le
besoin d'acheter si c'est pas nécessaire
ben oui à l'instant qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ben rien j'avais j'ai des j'avais
pris des articles et ils étaient pas ils
étaient soldés et quand je suis arrivé à
la caisse les soldes marchaient pas mais
bon c'est pas grave ils m'ont remboursé
il faut vérifier les les prix avant
quand même et tout pour savoir mais moi
après on a tous l'impression de faire
des bonnes affaires donc non enfin moi
j'ai je sais qu'on est arnaqué oui c'est
quelque fois pas tout le temps maisut
pas ma connaissance he maintenant c'est
vrai que on a pas souvent la la
visibilité sur le prix avant les soldes
mais très souvent je je sais où je vais
on va dire en général quels sont les
recours on peut saisir directement vos
services alors vous pouvez éventuell
vous pouvez évidemment saisir nos
services donc vous pouvez les saisir par
courriel euh donc le site c'est
ddpp@astiveline.gou.fr sinon vous pouvez
téléphoner également on a une permanence
consommation donc nos services euh donc
agissent sur plainte des consommateurs
et nos services également enquêtent dans
le cadre d'un programme national
d'enquête qui est mise en œuvre par la
DGCCRF on peut donner quelques conseils
aussi peut-être alors les alors les
conseils c'est c'est c'est toujours les
mêmes conseils c'est c'est-à-dire que
les consommateurs mais ils sont de toute
façon avertis ils vont faire il faut
faire des repérages euh voilà c'est ce
qu'il font avant les seuls pour bien
voir quels sont les prix pratiqués avant
les soldes euh il faut aussi bien
demander aux vendeurs et cetera parce
que quelquefois il peuent il peut avoir
des des information comme quoi le
magasin fait 80 % sur tous les articles
mais quelquefois dans le il y a il y a
pas entre les articles soldés et non
soldés les consommateurs s'y retrouvent
pas donc ils doivent demander quand même
avant euh de éventuellement se faire
arnaquer euh au vendeurs quels sont les
articles qui sont soldés et
d'ailleurs s'il y a une confusion entre
les articles soldés et non soldés dans
un magasin nos services sont chargés
éventuellement de relever des pratiques
commerciales trompeuse mais je dois dire
en fait que sur les contrôles qu'on fait
donc il y a à peu près 200 à 300
contrôles par par il y a à peu près un
taux d'infraction de de 15 % c'est en ha
ou c'est assez sable c'est constant
c'est c'est assez sable peut-être pour
conclure aussi cet entretien une
dernière distinction on parle des soldes
il y a aussi de plus en plus de ventes
privées de promotion tout au long de
l'année quelle distinction des périodes
de soldes ce qu'on appelle les les
promotions ne peuvent pas ne peuvent pas
être dénommés soldes on peut les appeler
promotions alors en ce qui concerne les
ventes privées les alors on voit
quelquefois juste avant les soldes des
mentions comme sold de privé mais seul
privé ce n'est pas toléré c'est ventes
privé et et en plus les ventes privées
doivent être réservé à des consommateurs
privilégiés qui ont une carte de
fidélité et à partir du moment où les
ventes privées s'appliquent à tout le
monde ce n'est plus une vente privée et
ça peut être considéré comme une
pratique commerciale trompeuse merci à
vous de toutes ces précisions concernant
les soldes qui débutent aujourd'hui et
qui vont donc se poursuivre jusqu'au 4
août et si vous avez la moindre
difficulté aussi problème il faut se
tourner vers la direction départementale
de la protection des populations merci à
vous cette polémique à présent dans le
journal Pierre Bédier pourrait réintégré
le conseil d'administration de l'opivois
c'est l'un des plus importants bailleurs
socials de France un office que le
président du conseil départemental avait
déjà présidé entre 94 et 2005 avant sa
condamnation en 2006 pour abus de biens
sociaux les explications Catherine
zulato et ho
moine Rodolphe Jacotin siège depuis 15
ans au conseil d'administration de
l'opivo en qualité d'administrateur
désignés par les locataires l'opivois
c'est l'un des plus importants bailleurs
sociaux de France avec 22000 logements
rien que dans les Yvelines l'annonce du
retour de Pierre Bédier président du
conseil départemental au sein du conseil
d'administration de l'opivois est loin
de le réjouir Pierre Bédier a pourtant
été président de l'office entre 1994 et
2005 mais il a été condamné en 2006 pour
recelle d'abus de biens sociaux et c'est
selon Rodolphe jacquotin incompatible
avec son retour au sein de l'oupivoie
bah au titre de la loi du Code de la
Construction normalement toute personne
qui qui a été condamné au titre de
l'article
l241 donc ne peut pas siéger au sein
d'un d'un organisme public avec la
condamnation pénale de de Pierre Bier
normalement il ne peut pas siéger au
sein d'un office public donc en
l'occurrence le pivoie qui est un office
public départemental de logement social
Rodolphe jaccotin a adressé un courrier
dans ce sens au préfet des ivelines et
au procureur de la République en
attendant le prochain conseil
d'administration qui pourrait se tenir
début juillet du côté du conseil
départemental la réponse est venue de
Carl olive conseiller départemental
président du groupe Ensemble pour les
Yvelines selon lui il s'agit d'une
vindicte contre les élus républicain
dans un communiqué de presse il évoque
une énième élucumertion le président de
l'épi rappelle que Pierre Bédier connaît
très bien le fonctionnement de l'office
et qu'il est temps de connaître la
situation réelle rodolp jaccotin de son
côté craint également un éclatement de
l'opivot interdépartemental en trois
entités nous ce qui nous inquiète en
tant que administrateur c'est la volonté
de Bédier de de départementaliser
l'Office alors que ce ce bailleur a
plutôt vocation maintenant l'échelle du
Grand Paris l'échelle des régions d' un
office régional donc une régionalisation
sera beaucoup plus pertinent qu'une
départementalisation à travers les
propos de pibd dans la presse et cette V
départementalisé il y a plein d'autres
choses qui jouent ces 1000 salariés
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de ces salariés
comment on va être dispatcher les les
logements dans le casadre
départementalisation fondé en 1920 le
Pivo gère aujourd'hui plus de 50000 log
ement réparti dans 7 départements
d'île-de-fance et emploie 930
collaborateurs politique le trésorier du
Front national valerand de Saint-Juste
sera tête de liste du Front national en
Île-de-France pour ces élections
régionales de décembre il entend réunir
20 % des électeurs là où les sondages le
créditent actuellement de 18 % son
ambition entre 26 et 31 sièges
actuellement la formation ne dispose
d'aucun élu l'exavocat de Jean-Marie Le
Pen va lancer officiellement sa campagne
fin septembre mais il a déjà a dévoilé
les contours de son programme c'était
lors d'un déplacement à Versailles vous
le voyez vous l'attendeit également
Michel elmidoro et elodim
moine nous insisterons beaucoup sur la
question de l'action économique de la
région et on est en train de mettre au
point un programme que je pense original
sur la question des transports et puis
aussi et surtout ce que j'ai appelé les
carartés délaissé
c'est-à-dire on connaît bien ça dans les
ivelines mais surtout plutôt en plus
encore dans le sud de les sones ou dans
l'est de la cénémarne beaucoup
d'endroits où il n'y a plus de service
public où il n'y a plus de commerçants
et pourtant où il y a beaucoup de gens
qui habitent et qui se sentent délaissés
et pour représenter les ivelines dans
ces élection régionale Philippe Chevrier
le responsable du parti d'extrême droite
dans le département a été désigné tête
de liste ces colistiers ne seront
dévoilés qu'à partir du 10 novembre les
noms de Cyril not le maire de
montelaville de François Siméoni élu
d'opposition à Versailles sont évoqué
quant à valerand de Saint-Juste il est
également revenu lors de sa visite à
Versailles sur le conflit qui oppose
Jean-Marie Le Pen à sa fille pour lui il
fallait suspendre le fondateur du parti
de son statut d'adhérent du Front
national ah ben je pense que de façon
très douloureuse il était absolument
obligatoire de mettre fin euh euh au au
au danger que représentait Jean-Marie Le
Pen pour l'avenir du Front national pour
tous les espoirs que les Français
mettent en nous mettent en Marine Le Pen
dans deélection présidentielle on est
les sondages nous disent 30% au prier
tour on ne peut plus se permettre le
moindre fa pas
essayer nous parlons d'Europe à présent
avec notre dossier thématique que nous
déroulons tout au long de la semaine
hier il était question du Service
volontaire européen aujourd'hui nous
vous présentons un autre programme de
mobilité move in Europe porté par la
Maison de l'Europe desel par l'émission
locale également le sujet
signé
[Musique]
vous avez entre 18 et 26 ans vous êtes
demandeur d'emploi ou inscrit dans une
mission locale l'Europe peut vous
permettre d'effectuer un stage
professionnel c'est le programme MVE in
Europe il faut savoir qu'il y a aussi
quelques programmes qui existent pour la
mobilité des professionnels qui
permettent donc à des salariés de
plusieurs structures de bénéficier d'une
période de mobilité à international
essentiellement en Europe pendant une
courte période mais qui permet à la fois
aussi bien pour les professionnels de
renforcer les compétences linguistique
et d'avoir cette expérience dans un
milieu professionnel à l'étranger qui
correspond à son domaine d'activité en
France le principal objectif d'une d'une
telle expérience et est d'abord
l'opportunité de pouvoir parler une
langue dans un milieu professionnel
parce que
souvent même si on maîtrise une langue
au
quotidien le la maîtrise d'un d'un
vocabula professionnel n'est pas
forcément spontané donc c'est l'objectif
principal et bien évidemment également
de d'avoir une expérience
professionnelle même courte à l'étranger
pour lui le candidat idéal serait
curieux motivé et avide de nouvelles
connaissances en langues étrangères il
suffit de se lancer comme l'a justement
fait Diara grâce à ce dispositif j'ai pu
partir de semaines à wing qui est une
ville qui se situe à 25 minutes de
Londres et au cours de ces de semaines
je suis partie j'ai eu d'abord une
semaine de de cour if en fait en anglais
avec deux professeurs particuliers donc
au cours de cette semaine j'ai pu avoir
des exercices en fait en langue
espagnole aussi des des expressions
écrites expression orale compréhension
écrite compréhension orale pour moi
cette première semaine déjà de de cours
en Angleterre était pour moi très
bénéfique et par la suite j'ai une
semaine de stage dans une dans un
bowling donc c'était vraiment pour moi
enfin une expérience pratique auparavant
j'avais un blocage quand je m'exprimais
en en anglais donc surtout j'ai assez
peu de vocabulaire et donc du mal à
m'exprimer et maintenant ce que je enin
ce que je pense c'est que j'ai beaucoup
plus d'isance à l'oral je suis vim
contente mon expérience et je la
recommande à tous les professionnels qui
souhaitent partir à l'étranger
perfectionner de contacter une structure
tel que la Maison de l'Europe qui
puisse les les les soutenir on va dire
dans leur démarche 1 Europ pass
passeport européen de compétence est
remis à chacun des jeunes pour couronner
tout projet de départ mené à bien depuis
2008 dans les Yvelines près d'une
centaine de jeunes ont profité de ce
dispositif et dernier volet demain de ce
dossier Europe culture 240 enfants de
l'agglomération des LAN cours Trapp et
de Montini le Bretonneux sur la scène du
théâtre national à 50 ans en Yveline
pour interpréter en et Gretel c'est le
fruit d'une année de travail encadrée
par des professionnels au final un très
beau résultat les images vous allez voir
sont signé Maxime
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
LEM dans
ch il y a 8 mois certains n'avaient
jamais chanté en moins d'une année ses
élèves de trappe d'élancour ou de
Montini se retrouvent sur la scène du
Théâtre national de 50 ans en Yveline
ils interprètent un opéra rien que cela
en ne s'allégrait-elle au début c'est
difficile parce que ils savent rien ils
n'ont pas l'habitude de chanter ils
savent pas respirer ils savent pas se
tenir il arrive pas à se concentrer
suffisamment moi je demande 50 minutes
de concentration ouais et et voilà et
après ça repart petit à petit il rentre
dans le projet commence à comprendre
l'histoire on fait des chansons on fait
des jeux il faut être ludique et il faut
être très patiente et il faut aimer les
enfants et après ça marche Gabriella
nous apprenait à être droit à écouter à
bien chanter et surtout et surtout être
bien j'ai ressenti énormément de joie on
était tous heureux tout le monde s'est
tout le monde a applaudi après c'est
[Musique]
magnifique
dismoi don est
sur un
pied
[Musique]
une une année de travail donc avec la
maîtrise de trappes et des solistes
professionnels très très lourd mais je
crois la mission accomplie parce qu'en
fait c'est on veut faire vraiment un
travail on veut pousser les enfants le
plus loin possible là nous avons 70 %
d'enfants de quartier priori
des quartiers de TR des lancour et en
fait ils s'investissent
énormément bientôt ils viendront dans la
forêt et là je les attends je les
capturerai et je les
m dans le rôle de la vilain sorcière qui
capture les deux enfants morindor
comédienne belge elle s'est dite
totalement emballé par le projet l'opéra
c'est pas la culture non plus de plein
de gens donc c'est ça qui est
merveilleux c'est une ambition totale
c'est ça l'intégration l'intégration
c'est exact ça me fait rire on peut dire
tout ce qu'on
veut l'intégration c'est de prendre des
enfants dans des écoles des enfants don
c'estit pas la culture l'opéra anneell
les Gretel et cetera le champ classique
et tout le monde va venir voir merci les
enfants retournez voir vos parents et
vous aussi les enfants retournez dans
vos familles et soyez heureux soyez
[Musique]
joyeux et pour un point complet sur
l'actualité locale rendez-vous juste
après ce journal comme chaque mercredi
pour kiosk présenté préparé par
Catherine zulato environnement pour
terminer cette édition du 18 au 20 juin
c'était les Happy Days 3 jours autour de
la sensibilisation des abeilles un
insecte pollinisateur indispensable à la
biodiversité mais en déclin la ferme
pédagogique de l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin à participer à ces
différentes journées en proposant des
ateliers qui ont été suivis par Mélanie
poquet mauvais pass pour les abeilles
ces insectes pollinisateurs sont en
déclin en 2014 10000 tonnes de miel ont
été produites c'est trois fois moins
qu'il y a 20 ans à la ferme pédagogique
de Saint-Quentin en Yveline on a décidé
de sensibiliser il y a une
méconnaissance des personnes par rapport
au produit du miel par exemple où on va
acheter du miel où il y a juste écrit
miel donc on sait pas la provenance ça
peut venir de très très loin pas
forcément être du miel de fleur aussi
donc après on essaie justement de
sensibiliser un peu les personnes parce
que c'est aussi ça qui fera qu'il y aura
plus d'abeilles plus d'apiculteurs qui
pourront vivre de leur métier et plus de
pollinisateurs du coup environ 100000
abeilles se partagent les ciruges de la
ferme pédagogique qui produit du miel
d'acacia et de châignier de quoi
multiplier les ateliers morphologie de
l'insecte bougie en cire et même
extraction du préciux liquide je voulais
voir en vrai la ruche avec extraction
voir si les abeilles étaient agressives
à extraction apparemment c'était très
très calme et puis surtout discuter avec
l'apiculteur pour voir les tout ce qui
technique d'extraction puis aussi au
niveau législation ce qu'il faut faire
et cetera on regarde comment vous faites
et puis ce que vous a retrouvé comme
comme miel surtout parce que moi par
exemple je sais que le miel tout les
matins c'est une cuillère de miel
systématiquement dans le thé c'est
délicieux et puis en plus on pêche les
angines il y a plein de choses on peut
guérir des plai avec ça c'est un
désaffectant avant tout amoureux des
abeilles juste curieux une centaine de
personnes ont fait le
déplacement fin de ce journal
rendez-vous demain aux horaires
habituels pour un nouveau point complet
sur l'actualité locale des Evelin replay
de cette émission des précédentes
émissions également sur notre site
Internet à demain
[Musique]
jeudi